yes my favorite show of 2018 has
officially been renewed for season 2 The
Haunting of Hill House will return as an
anthology season with the new season
officially titled the haunting of Bligh
Manor be sure to stick around for the
end of this video because I'm gonna
break down the thirty second teaser
found on the haunting of Hill House's
Twitter and you don't want to miss the
clues that this gives away it looks like
the crane family will not be returning
for season two as carla Gugino told The
Hollywood Reporter that creator Mike
Flanagan said he feels like he has told
the complete story of the crane family
but don't count the actors out since
Flanagan expressed interest in doing
something similar to American Horror
Story where they come back as new
characters so even though this will be a
new story with new characters it's
possible we could still see the actors
who did an amazing job in season one
returning will we see hell house it's
unconfirmed at this point but if it does
it likely won't play a large role if any
at all the theme of season 2 focuses on
a new mansion entirely fly Manor the
setting of Henry James is 1898 gothic
horror novella of the turn of the screw
screw takes place in an old country
mansion where two young orphans are
looked after by a governess who's
convinced the grounds are haunted the
exact nature of the evil found in turn
of the screw is open to interpretation
similar to how the ghosts in season 1
aren't entirely explained now the teaser
video currently only available in the
hauntings Twitter page States a new
haunting is coming can you guess where
it takes place listen closely if it's
based off the novella then this season
will most likely occur in the English
countryside however it being an
adaptation it's possible they may change
the locale to somewhere in the United
States blind Manor also seems to take
place somewhere cold the whistling wind
and small snowflakes seemed to hint that
not to mention that turn of the screw
starts on Christmas Eve we then get a
flurry of whispers the sound of the
floor creaking or perhaps a rocking
chair or rocky
or s-- the quote said by the woman here
is from page 35 of the novella itself
the terrace and the whole place the lawn
in the garden beyond it all I could see
of the park were empty with a great
emptiness this is a reference to the
governess recounting her experience was
seeing a ghost through a window at Bly
Manor she ran outside to catch a better
glimpse of it but upon getting there was
met with nothing a great emptiness the
mention of the garden is also
significant by many literature critics
who highlight how the story of screw is
an allegory for Adam and Eve and the
Garden of Eden with the two children
miles and flora being swayed by the
ghostly entities of Bly Manor like Adam
and Eve were swayed by the God and devil
and with turn of the screw having
children in it it's likely that some of
the amazing child actors from season one
may make an appearance of course we
won't know for sure until 2020 so make
sure you're subscribed to my channel
where I'll be dissecting the trailers
episodes and if you haven't checked out
my season 1 analysis give it a look
until next time catch you in the Red
Room and remember daddy loves you very
much